I'm joined now by the former community
secretary and may backer sir Eric
Pickles and we're hearing and very good
morning to you sir Eric we're hearing it
all so some people are saying well she
could turn out to be and really led some
the the jeremy corbyn of the
Conservative Party I've been lost
probably aggro some exaggeration and I
think it's now gonna be up to the
members to decide and mitad lee andrew
has had what might charitably be
described as a disastrous start to her
campaign but she's got a a chance now to
make a points to the membership what
does that disastrous start tell us as
you term it to her campaign what does it
tell us about her potential qualities as
a as a prime minister doesn't tell us
very much I think she gave a button to
you our first major interview with a
very serious journal and she fluffed it
she messed it up and to make it worse
she then accused that for a senior
journalist of of engaging in gutter
politics I don't like to see those kind
of reactions and their potential prime
minister because she's going to have to
deal with a lot more tougher people than
than than the particular journalist
Rachel stove Esther I think mr. Putin
might be just a little bit more
difficult and then we have therefore the
foreign secretary saying how most of the
people he's been talking to in Warsaw I
have never heard all in all those of you
on the on the may side saying she just
wouldn't cut it well I think she's got
some a lot of potential and she probably
should have waited and and look for her
chances in a future leadership election
she may possibly be blowing her chances
forever as a potential leader I don't
know her at all well I think I've heard
her speak maybe three or four times and
two of those were about up the Hosting's
and she's and some ones have really
crossed Mont Merida she seems pleasant
enough but yeah I'm really looking for
somebody with strength and determination
and what about this issue of her CV her
business experience in particular
experience in the city some say she
wasn't in as many senior positions is
she
claim to me but even if she was it's
that exactly something's going to appeal
to the country at large that you were in
the city just before they crashed the
economy in 2008 well I'm sure she had a
very distinguished career in the city I
have no idea I'm told we're going to get
a definitive biography early fairly soon
but I think people are looking for
someone with enormous empathy and a kind
of understanding what it's like to be
struggling to to bring up most a family
but you know see the prospects in
schools or prospects for people retiring
and I think Teresa fits all those bills
but do you think that was a low blow you
think she meant to mention that contrast
cuts up with reason a and having that
stake in the future because she's got
children and Theresa May doesn't well I
described as tacky when it first came
out and then I heard the recording and I
actually thought the recording put her
in a worse position than before but what
worries me not so much because you know
these things happen I was surprised she
didn't have her own recording of the
interview
I'm surprised if you thought it was
wrong she didn't ring very quickly and
try and get the headline adjusted but
there doesn't seem to be anything
particularly unfair you know she came up
against a top-notch journalist top knows
journalists wants to make news she asked
her an obvious question
it was a ginormous elephant trap and she
fell into elephant trap and then
continued to make it deeper got in a
hole or kept digging in your estimation
what about though this argument within
the party that in reality your next
leader has to come from the leave side
this idea that some if they could in a
parallel universe both go away and come
back with the same deal which inevitably
involves some compromise with European
Union to get access to the single market
or whatever but that Andrea led some is
better positioned to sell compromise to
the party than Theresa May is because
she was on the remain side well a few
feet from where we're sitting
she was described by very senior
Excalibur it was a bloody difficult
woman and I think I'd rather have a
bloody difficult woman negotiating for
me than someone who panics over a
slightly unfortunate interview and makes
it worse and is there any I mean what
are you hearing within the party around
the bars and the conversations you're
all having how worried are they about an
Andrea led some leadership this idea
we're reading in the paper there that
some MP is saying well we couldn't serve
under her I would tell you that with an
enormous pinch of salt I just don't
believe that I know it's been a very
turbulent couple of weeks but the idea
of of members of conservative parties
splitting away to form some Santa group
I think is ludicrous I think most
members of parliament would support
Theresa May that was pretty obvious in
terms of of the votes but ultimately
democracy demands that our membership
picks our leader do you think though
then whoever wins it can reunite the
party are you saying that Andrea led
some actually couldn't well I hope she
would it was very noticeable on the full
Hosting's
that she was the only candidate that
didn't talk about bringing us all back
together again and I think and I hope
this doesn't sound wrong but in terms of
bringing the Conservative Party is the
first step towards bring in the rest of
the nation together we have to remember
an awful lot of people voted on the
losing side of the referendum and the
government needs to speak for for
everybody one of the symbols I mean
Teresa may said it explicitly brexit
means brexit we understand that but it's
this triggering this formal triggering
of article 50 or not entirely clear
especially when we hear from the former
attorney general Dominick grieve
suggesting that well perhaps it could
lead to a renegotiation the brexit vote
Marino's article 50 might not ever be
triggered it needs to be triggered when
all our Ducks are in a row we need to
have the very clearest idea
particularly with regard to financial
services which is a big part of our
economy whether or not we're going to be
able to treat an instruments involving
or involving euros and I think until we
get that would be very foolish to
trigger it I'm not sure we're under ears
on this I heard she wanted to trigger it
straight to where she told us that those
things that she didn't and I now hear I
think that she wants to trigger it
fairly soon so I'm I'm not sure my view
is we trigger it with you know when
we're ready it's a warm important card
that we've got in our hands with regard
to negotiation well it's a one-way
street there isn't it cause whether or
not you're finished you negotiators
after two years you're out so you use
the phrase you use the phrase ducks in a
row just having a look at Teresa Maher
at about the small and going to church
this morning in central London how long
does it take to get your ducks in the
row these are complex issues when you're
Prime Minister in place we need to have
a very clear idea but I want to make
absolutely clear brexit does mean
breakfast we are leaving the European
but your sense I mean you're talking
about this issue of past boarding as
it's called for the City of London than
the financial services I mean that's
hugely complex it could take months it's
it's a very big deal
I've already had people in my surgery on
Friday very worried about their jobs
people are coming across from one of the
larger banks from America to talk to the
staff deals have been offered in in in
Paris and in Dublin for the transfer of
those jobs so you know we need to kind
of retain as many jobs as we can in
these services